[Música]
eu fui atleta ou muitos anos e quando
parei de competir eu sentia aquele baque
aquela falta de disposição que acompanha
quem pára de treinar
repentinamente mas na verdade quando eu
digo que eu parei de treinar e não parei
de fato eu não parei por completo de
fazer exercício físico o que continuava
caminhando subir a escada
agora imaginem vocês estão sentados
algumas horas
imagine se tivesse sentado anos sem
conseguir mexer os músicos das próprias
pernas
imagine um benefício que sentiriam se
pudesse voltar a exercitar as próprias
pernas
pois é exatamente é dessa população que
gostaria de conversar com vocês aqui
hoje de pessoas que sofreram uma lesão
na medula
dependendo do nível da lesão da altura
em que ela ocorrer na coluna essas
pessoas podem perder o movimento das
pernas e das mãos
mas essa não é dos principais desafios
que as pessoas enfrentam no dia a dia
eu acho que o que mais dificulta é na
verdade uma sociedade inclusiva
o ambiente não acessível uma tecnologia
limitada
as rodas são as pernas não cadeirantes
mas quando ele veio aqui encontra uma
escada e não consegue chegar onde ele
quer ir às nossas mãos nos permitem
escrever criar fazer música mas os
medicamentos de hoje em dia não
conseguem restaurar esses movimentos
perdidos
nós precisamos de tecnologia em poder e
meio da mobilidade e autonomia
essa tecnologia hoje já existe
a estimulação elétrica funcional por
meio de estímulos de baixa energia
aplicados nos nervos o mesmo sobre a
pele
nós conseguimos ativar os músculos gera
força mas é algo diferente daqueles é
dos esqueletos mecânicos e colocamos
sobre a pele porque o estímulo elétrico
é percebido pelo corpo como um comando
do próprio
a estimulação elétrica ela conversa a
linguagem a língua natural do sistema
nervoso
é nesse vídeo
nós vemos a mariana a mariana não
consegue controlar os próprios
movimentos
hoje ela está experimentando a
estimulação elétrica pela primeira vez
aqui a gente consegue ver que a gente
consegue controlar o movimento gerando
esse movimento alternado que nós
queríamos mas são ainda movimentos
irregulares há espasmos a uma fadiga
acelerada
infelizmente hoje em dia essa tecnologia
ainda não permite que consigamos
restaurar movimentos complexos como
caminhar mas alguns tipos de movimento
já conseguimos estabelecer com esse tipo
de tecnologia
hoje em dia já é possível pedalar
essa é a ema trick
neste ciclo nós embarcamos computador
sensores e um eletro simulador permite
que pessoas com paraplegia sem o
controle movimento das pernas possa
voltar a exercitar suas pernas e quem
sabe até pedalar
esse sistema ele controla diversos
músculos ativando precisamente o músico
no instante em que ele precisa se
ativado para gerar um movimento da
pedalada mas essa aqui não é uma
história apenas de avanço de ciência e
tecnologia
essa história também de como fazer as
coisas realmente juntos eu sou
engenheiro como engenheiros e um grande
prazer em fazer as coisas mas encontrei
minha maior motivação desenvolvendo
tecnologia para a saúde ea tecnologia
não se desenvolve sozinho
nós precisamos antes de projetar de
programar de conversar com o outro de
escutar sobre a realidade
então pra entender um pouco mais desse
mundo com vida aqui pra vocês
meu amigo teve lops
brasília 7 de março de 2012
lembro bem uma terça feira à noite é me
preparo para o aniversário de um amigo
me produzo me arrumo roupa aniversário
me divirto à beça
a festa maravilhosa na hora de ir embora
me dirijo ao encontro do meu carro e
para minha surpresa acontece uma troca
de tiros uma bala perdida atingiu minhas
costas
a partir daquele momento perco do
movimento da minha cintura para baixo e
não sinto mais minhas pernas me torna
paraplégico
precisando de uma cadeira de rodas para
se locomover posso falar com propriedade
o assunto exposto pelo antônio porque
durante três longos anos
eu fiquei nessa situação sem sequer ver
minha perna ter qualquer tipo de
movimento
mas aí conhecia a estimulação
confesso que no começo fiquei receoso
porque os avanços propostos para mim era
um avanço em três anos eu nunca
imaginaria que podia alcançar e lembra
que até me ajuda fisioterapeuta falou o
seguinte cara você pode voltar até
pedalar e falei cara voltar pedalando
mexo nenhum dedo
quanto mais pedalar que história é essa
enfim mais uma nova tecnologia porque
não arriscar e testá-la testei e para
minha grata surpresa realmente os
avanços que estava sendo proposto ali
aconteceu de uma forma maior do que eu
esperava
eu sinto uma passagem legal que é o
seguinte todo mundo aí a grande maioria
deve ter malhado praticada academia sabe
quanto é difícil você ter um ganho de
massa muscular
com mais ou menos uns seis meses sete
meses de treino com a legislação
alcancei 12 centímetros de petrofina
minhas coxas
não só isso é a minha circulação a minha
pele melhorou eu via minha perna e uma
perna normal e com isso tudo o ganho da
autoestima
você tá ali me apenas um guarda antes
tão sensacional
estevam mas quando pra gente como foi a
sensação de voltar a controlar as pernas
a outra vez
então você imagina né muito tempo ali
sem nem movimentar a perna e eu comecei
a dar as primeiras pedaladas meio
desconcertados de qualquer jeito mas ali
enfim eram pedaladas né
eu estava vivendo na situação de pedalar
uma sensação indescritível surreal eu
saí de um de um outro mundo no mundo que
não movimentava as pernas e ele
continuava pedalar de novo e o mais
importante é que o que essa nova
tecnologia que foi passada para mim não
ficaria só em mim que sou um atleta de
alto rendimento que sou um atleta para a
limpo essa tecnologia se estenderia para
as pessoas é normais a a cadeirante que
é a dona de casa que tem uma vida ociosa
que é sedentário é o senhor aposentado
que tem um sonho de voltar a pedalar de
novo e aí me fez mais ainda entrar de
cabeça nesse projeto e eu me dediquei é
realmente virou o meu projeto de vida e
eu entrei e me tornei o piloto do
projeto emma e aí os três passaram a ser
treinos constantes diários
é o convívio com a equipe todo dia ali
melhorando vendo aquela pedalada
melhorar nos passou de um patamar de
equipe e nos tornamos uma família que
hoje eu falo com propriedade nós não
somos a equipe ema
nós somos a família emma essa história
ela ficou aqui em brasília ela foi para
um lugar legal
gente eu vou mostrar pra vocês olhem sei
cara vamos assistir comigo um cara e não
mexia nem o dedo
olha isso não é surreal não é
sensacional
olha isso aí
[Aplausos]
isso aí é uma competição que se chama
saibam popularmente chamada de
olimpíadas biônicas essa competição a se
reunir ela reúne as maiores empresas de
tecnologia do mundo todo
as maiores universidades do mundo
buscando a melhor tecnologia e tava
japão estados unidos
o mundo todo e para a minha maior
surpresa e e pra gratifica esse equipe
toda
nós conseguimos chegar até a final e
hoje eu fico até emocionado e arrepiado
porque hoje eu pedalo eu sou ciclista eu
sou piloto do projeto ema
vocês vão ver um cadeirante em brasília
pedalando não com as mãos mas com as
pernas
valeu galera
[Aplausos]
[Música]